black widow introduced viewers to a ton
of russian superheroes
and super villains straight out of the
pages of marvel comics
but how do black widow and the rest of
the cast compare with their comics
incarnations
natalia alianova romanov aka natasha
romanov was created in 1964 as femme
fatale madame natasha
sent by khrushchev to seduce and
distract tony stark
after being foiled by iron man black
widow goes on the run for months
avoiding a return to russia and a
confrontation with her superiors over
her failure
in these early appearances natasha's
look is definitely more spy
and less super villain it's when the
character returned in june 1966 as a
brainwashed supervillain in avengers
issue 29 that she got her first
costume which included fishnet stockings
a cape clasped with a bee around her
neck
and a mask after a few more years black
widow decided to reinvent herself as a
superhero
by going after spider-man drawing one of
his jay jonah jameson imposed public
ministries no less
and done the black cat suit so commonly
associated with her image in the comics
as well as the mcu so far marvel hasn't
exactly been adventurous when it comes
to black widow's look in the mcu
just about the only part of her
appearance to change has been her hair
which has gone through a few different
styles and colours most notably when she
went from red-headed to blonde
after the events of captain america
civil war which puts her at odds with
the united states government and made
her
a fugitive along with the rest of cap's
crew although she's been known to wear
office attire or even an evening gown
when she's undercover
or on assignment her battle suits
throughout the first decade of the
franchise
have pretty much all been basically
black however that changes with the
black widow movie
which gives her a brand new outfit and
pulls back the curtain on natasha's
mysterious past
prior to joining up with the avengers
one black widow's suit we haven't seen
in previous mcu films
is what's become known in the comics as
the tactical suit
first introduced to audiences in the
2010 four issue miniseries
black widow deadly origin it was
designed specifically to blend into
snowy landscapes
so the suit's utility in the russian
tundra is undeniable
and this new outfit definitely comes in
handy during natasha's 2021 solo outing
in order to find the location of the red
room black widow and her adoptive sister
elena bolova
have to fly into a russian prison and
break out their old adoptive dad
alexei shostakov and with all that snow
the tactical suit
totally fits the moment while she does
spend the majority of the movie wearing
her traditional black outfit
her time in white drawing black widow is
a nod to the characters illustrious
comics past
one of the new characters introduced in
black widow is yelena bulova
a fellow spy who's a graduate of the
infamous red room when natasha was
trained as a girl
essentially she's another black widow on
top of that she's natasha's adoptive
sister
and someone who feels a little hurt
about her big sis running off
joining the avengers and leaving her
behind bolova's first comic appearance
came in in humans volume 2
issue 5 in 1999 and in the years since
she's co-headlined several mini-series
with natasha under the black widow
mantle
in comics form elena likes to wear crop
tops and spandex
not exactly practical when fighting in
the film however pugh's elena dresses
more appropriately for combat
and she's definitely got a thing for
vests that are full of pockets
rachel vice joins the ranks of academy
award-winning actors in the mcu
by playing melina vastakov in the black
widow movie here molina is a spy
dedicated to the course of the red room
when we first meet her she's living
under cover in america
raising natasha and elena alongside
alexei shostakov
later on we find out that she's a key
player in developing the techniques that
the villainous drakov uses to control
the widows
although she eventually comes to see the
error of her waist
in the comics vostakov is known as the
iron maiden a russian assassin with deep
ties to natasha
her costume of choice is a flexible full
body armor that increases her strength
as well as protecting her from damage
unfortunately that awesome outfit
doesn't show up in the film
instead molina wears a more traditional
black widow suit
and while it lacks the intimidating
armor of iron maiden's comic book attire
it's still a pretty fantastic costume
one of the few characters joining black
widow is rick mason
in the comics mason is a freelance
mercenary and ex-shield agent
the mcu portrays him somewhat
canonically but one new wrinkle here is
that the filmmakers have given him a bit
of a romantic
sexual tension with natasha in the
comics mason's just a regular shady guy
no super suit involved and that's
basically the version we get on the
screen
having said that his ability to wrangle
up anything natasha needs
is pretty super in and of itself one of
the more striking characters in black
widow is alexei schasterkoff
also known as red guardian he's
basically the russian version of captain
america
portrayed by david harbour although
there have been multiple red guardians
throughout marvel comics history
harbour is playing one of the more
complicated men to wear the costume
shostakov's backstory is a mile long but
the highlights include
actually being married to natasha dying
and coming back as a robot and then as a
zombie
and even taking over clint barton's
ronin identity
in the mcu's black widow shows the
coppers natasha
and elena's adoptive father but their
history together is similarly mad by
betrayal distrust
and emotional pain i couldn't be more
proud of you
you smell really bad general thaddeus e
thunderbolt russ is one of the oldest
supporting characters in marvel comics
history
he's been around since the first issue
of the incredible hulk in 1962
william hurt has portrayed ross in
multiple mcu movies
making his first turner's ross in 2008's
the incredible hulk
first seen as a lieutenant general in
the u.s army ross returned in 2016's
captain america
civil war now the secretary of state
like the mcu's rust the character has
hunted the hulk in the comics
but on the page he's undergone some
severe transformations
in his obsession to defeat the hulk at
any cost russ himself hogged out as red
hulk
hoping to match his nemesis pound for
pound things didn't work out of course
and after cutting a swath through much
of the marvel universe
ross settled into an uneasy hero role
albeit one with extreme anger issues
unfortunately he never goes into hulk
mode drawing black widow
but it's still nice to see the
oscar-winning actor in the mcu
for a long time marvel refused to tell
us he was playing the villainous
taskmaster
in black widow but the trailers showed
the character in action
delivering some pretty sweet
action-packed moves the illustrated
version of the taskmaster has a super
complicated backstory
but then doesn't everyone in marvel tony
masters was a shield agent who was
exposed to the nazi version of the super
soldier
serum that turns steve rogers into
captain america
but in master's case it enhanced his
photographic reflexes
giving him the power to instantly learn
mimic and mirror an opponent's fighting
style
that's made him exceptionally difficult
to beat as he's torn his way through the
marvel universe
when it comes to their outfits the comic
book taskmaster looks a lot like the
mcu's villain
the movie character's outfit is faithful
to the spirit of the comics
if not slavish and execution of course
when it comes to who's wearing the mask
the marvel cinematic universe goes in a
completely different direction
instead of it being tony masters
mimicking natasha's moves
this time it's antonia drakov the
daughter of the villain who's running
the red room
and someone who natasha has run into
before
can you can you wipe out
that much red
drakoff's daughter it's a nice little
twist one that's connected to natasha
romanoff's feelings of intense guilt
about her past and it helps take the
character of taskmaster in new and
exciting directions
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one